blastlight is the world's smallest
and most convenient uvc disinfection
light to help
keep you safe against covid19
i take mine everywhere i go go to
davidpakman.com
light to get it for forty percent off
the link is down below
we're starting today with a story that
comes to us
from the uh the poorest country in the
western hemisphere the country of haiti
where the haitian president was
assassinated
in his home early yesterday morning the
new york times has a very good article
summing this up called haiti's president
assassinated
in nighttime raid shaking a fragile
nation
a group of assailants stormed mr moize's
residence
early on wednesday shooting him and
wounding his wife
the interim prime minister declaring a
state of
siege the first explosions took place
around 1am and uh
this took place at the home of president
jovenel moz and this is a
a wealthy neighborhood residents
immediately feared
two of the terrors that have plagued the
nation gang violence or an earthquake
but by the morning they had learned that
the president
was dead a group of assailants had
stormed mr moz's residency
on the outskirts of the capital
port-au-prince early wednesday
shooting him and wounding his wife
martin mois
in what officials called a well-planned
operation that included foreigners who
spoke
spanish much is being made of the
spanish aspect of it
although it's it's really too early to
know too much about what that means
in a televised broadcast to the nation
the nation's interim prime minister
claude joseph
appealed for calm and presented himself
as the new head of government
announcing that he and his fellow
ministers had declared a state of siege
and placed haiti under a form of martial
law
the assassination left a political void
that deepened the turmoil and violence
that has gripped haiti for months
threatening to tip one of the world's
most troubled nations further
into lawlessness you know i'm not sure
how much people in the audience know
about the history of haiti
um haiti is on a land mass
that is uh an island that is shared with
another country the dominican republic
uh haiti in the east and the dominican
republic i'm sorry haiti in the west and
the dominican republic to the east the
island is called espanola
and there are really really
racist crude ex quote explanations that
are given
for why okay the dominican republic is
not a wealthy country but it is
significantly better off than haiti
which is the poorest country in the west
and
you maybe you can imagine what that
racist analysis is but it's quite this
simple
uh haiti is black people whereas the
dominican republic
is uh latino folks often of
with more of of european origin i mean
that's the that's the white nationalist
sort of crude racist explanation for
the disparity between haiti and the
dominican republic
economically and in other ways now this
is actually something that's been
studied extensively
jared diamond in his book collapse which
i read just not too long ago
actually talks a lot about it and uh
when you understand
the differences in haiti and the
dominican republic including
the placement of haiti in the west and
the dominican republic in the east and
what that means in terms of current what
that means in terms of
rainfall elevation early deforestation
happening in haiti due to lack of other
natural resources you really start to
understand that there's a very complex
situation in fact in the country and
unfortunately this has led to a
situation of significant
instability in haiti political problems
environmental
degradation and so many other things and
now this on top of it
just a horrible horrible situation the
new york times adding the details of who
shot the president and why remained
unknown
four people suspected of being involved
in the assassination were killed by the
police in a gun battle
and two others were arrested haiti's
police chief said late yesterday
the chief leon charles also said that
three police officers who had been held
hostage were
freed the authorities did not name any
of the suspects or cite any evidence
linking them to the assassination the
other thing i think that's important to
mention is there were some early
mentions of the assailants claimed to be
dea
now the american dea the drug
enforcement agency does have a presence
in haiti
and um they're it's
it's still so early that there were some
folks who immediately said oh
the dea carried this out every
indication so far
is that the assailants falsely claimed
to be
dea agents there is no evidence at this
time that the dea carried out this
assassination this doesn't mean that the
u.s
see through the cia and other agencies
hasn't been involved in political
assassinations in the past that's not
what it means it just means in this case
there is no evidence that that's that's
the reality
all we know is that the assailants
claimed to be dea agents based on
one report so we're going to continue
following this of course the hope is
that haiti does not devolve into even
more chaos and instability because
that's the last thing that the haitian
people
need there have already been some uh
questions about
will the u.s help and i know that that
makes a lot of people very
very scared of what does it mean when
the u.s helps
in the caribbean in central america and
in latin america and i get that
uh but let's let's keep our analyses
based on what is known
rather than what is hypothesized or
speculated
at this point in time and hopefully in
the next two to three days there's going
to be more clarity there
we are starting to see a softening in
the pandemic recovery
and yeah some of it has to do with
anti-vaxxers um what has been a
fantastic
you know 80 85 even 90 recovery
from the pandemic and i mean
economically and i also mean from a
public health standpoint
is now slowing down now you might be
saying whoa hold david wait a second
are you criticizing the state of play
in the united states during a democratic
administration i thought you were a
democratic chill
or a shiel as someone recently called me
uh no
you you guys know many of you know i've
never been a democrat i don't really
care about the democratic party
i just call things the way they are and
we are now seeing
jobless claims up and higher than
expected initial jobless claims
uh for the week ending july 3rd came in
at 373
000 new jobless claims that's higher
than the 350 000 that was expected
initial unemployment claims had been on
the decline big picture for months now
but we're now seeing a reversal jobless
claims going up
meanwhile there are broader concerns
about
the global economic comeback anecdotally
japan has now declared a state of
emergency
in tokyo and covid cases are surging
globally they're surging in a number of
countries and overall
and they're also up a bit actually close
to 20 percent
in the united states check out these
numbers around the world
cases had bottomed out in mid-june
at about 360 000 a day globally
cases are now up 12 just in the last few
weeks to over 400
000 cases a day this is believed to be
mostly because of the more contagious
delta variant these
you know sometimes people see something
on the news more contagious delta
variant that doesn't really mean
anything no
we are seeing because it spreads more
easily 12
more cases globally per day there's now
an even more contagious
lambda variant we don't yet know much
about it which could be
the next to spread and become dominant
so cases
up 12 globally in the united states
cases are up 20 we had gotten down to
about 12 000 cases a day in the us
we are now up to more than 14 000 cases
a day
in the u.s that is a big jump now so far
fortunately we are not seeing higher
deaths but remember that deaths lag
cases by weeks the hope would be the
optimistic
scenario is even though we're seeing
more cases because delta's more
contagious
if you're vaccinated you still are
unlikely to get hospitalized
if you get the virus and you're unlikely
to die if you get the virus if you are
vaccinated that's the hope
we don't really know that yet we need
another three to four weeks to see if
that's the case and meanwhile
20 percent of americans still don't want
the vaccine
if you care about public health you
would go and you would get the vaccine
if you care about the economy you would
go and you would get the vaccine
if you care about avoiding another sort
of shutdown to some degree in the fall
you would go and you get the vaccine
what are we doing here let's put up this
pathetic chart of u.s vaccinations per
day
and you will see if you were watching
today that we are basically down to the
level of daily vaccination that we saw
in january
now think back to that okay in january
we had almost no vaccines it was health
care workers and i think we were
starting to make the vaccine available
to the oldest and most vulnerable we are
vaccinating the same amount of people
now when we have full availability you
just walk in
in many places you don't even need an
appointment you just get vaccinated and
somehow
we are vaccinating no more people over
the last week
than we were doing in mid-january when
availability was close to
not not literally zero but it was very
very low
and in other countries people are just
sitting there waiting
for the privilege of having the vaccine
access
that we have and we are seeing it
reflected
not just in the case numbers but in the
economic uncertainty as well and so my
appeal is
if you don't care about other people if
you don't care about
if you just don't want to get vaccinated
because you have assessed that you were
at low risk either accurately or not and
you don't really care about other people
or whatever else
do you care about the economy because
the economy
is wrapped up in the success of the
public health recovery
come on guys the world is desperate for
the vaccines that we have
an overflow of just go and get
vaccinated uh
let me know your thoughts on this do you
think that this will continue to worsen
or is this a temporary blip as we
hopefully
get closer and closer to herd immunity
let me know you can find me on twitter
at deepakman and we will see i mean
listen but
ten days from now we'll have the answer
and hopefully
it is a positive one and not a negative
one
one of our sponsors is blastlight the
smallest and most
convenient uv disinfection light on the
market
covet is not over there are new variants
there might be future resurgences so of
course
it's still important to take precautions
keep yourself safe keep people around
you
safe uvc lights have been proven to
safely and rapidly kill bacteria
mold fungi and viruses including covid19
blast light is a convenient keychain uvc
light that you can take
wherever you go i keep it attached to my
keys
it goes everywhere with me it's easy to
use it disinfects any surface in just
seconds
with a really long battery life and it's
rechargeable i've looked at a bunch of
different uvc light
options and this is by far the most
compact and portable one out there
blast light is normally 99 but my
audience can get it for 40 percent off
which comes to 59.50 when you go to
davidpakman.com
blastlight the link is underneath this
video
remember that the david pakman show does
depend on the support
of people in our audience to fund the
program and to do the things that we do
the primary source of that funding
is a membership you can sign up at
joinpakman.com we do an extra show every
single day
for people who are members it's quite a
show i will tell you that
and you can use the coupon code better21
if you would like a discount i say just
give everybody the discount who cares
get people involved you can sign up at
joinpakman.com
and enjoy the bonus show almost
instantly
and yesterday's was a doozy let me put
it that way so
i have an admission to make that might
strike you as a weird thing for someone
who hosts a show about american politics
to say
i absolutely hate politics i hate it and
what i mean by that is
not that i don't care about the issues
that i talk about on the show
i care deeply about the issues that i
address on the show
what i mean is i hate the fact that the
reason
the show is the way it is and that
elections are the way they are
and that the country is the way that it
is and the political system we have is
the one we have
is based on a huge portion of this
country
being a combination of ignorant bad
faith actors and people whose views
are completely retrograde and
antithetical
immorally antithetical to the direction
that we as a country and as a human race
should be going
i hate that this is what politics is in
the united states
i don't like the fact that when i take
phone calls from the audience part of
what i have to do
because the alternative is to allow it
to go unchallenged
i hate that part of what i have to do is
talk to people
with just terrible ignorant disgusting
ideas
rooted in misunderstandings of how the
world works
and a backwards morality that i find to
be despicable to put it
to put it lightly i don't want to have
people like that in my life
it's optional that such people exist it
doesn't have to be this way we could
have
a more informed and educated population
but this is what it is
and i hate the fact that this is what it
means
to engage in politics in the united
states it's dealing with these horrible
people and bad ideas
i hate that because of these reactionary
right-wing movements
when we have a pandemic we actually have
to fight people just to get them to
accept uncontroversial science
it's a waste of time but it has to be
done because it's what we're dealing
with
i hate that when we could be figuring
out i don't know
how to move away from dirty energy and
start treating the planet with some
respect and
reorganizing our economies and societies
to be more sustainable
we're still dealing with people who just
don't accept the science
we're still dealing with people who you
know they don't think abortion should be
legal
or that two gay people should be able to
legally get married it's disgusting it's
a waste of time look at what we have to
deal with
because of how things work in the united
states and one of the real frustrations
of american politics
is that much like some aspects of
consumer culture
we're wasting time thinking about the
wrong things
what i mean by that is i recently
watched
some great interviews with the um late
author david foster wallace
whose book infinite jest i'm reading now
and one of the things that struck me
about his sort of critique of consumer
culture
and even david foster wallace's critique
of much of the
kind of literary analysis space is that
we spend very little time
actually thinking about are we thinking
about the right things
and when we look at the points of focus
for american politics and media
uh is the reality that these are the
things we focus on
because there are people that are so
ignorant and reactionary that they want
to fight us
on them you then start to realize how
much we're really
missing in our ability to make progress
and i'll give you some examples
here in the united states the modern
political media space
ends up saying very little about what
are some of the biggest questions of our
time right now
are we as a human race advanced enough
and wealthy enough to end abject poverty
end that degree of human suffering and
make sure
everybody is at least housed and fed
this is a really fundamental and basic
question
and the answer is obviously yes it's a
matter of political will
we should just be figuring out hey you
know what we've got the money and we've
got the know-how
let's end abject poverty let's end
global hunger
but it becomes completely intractable
because we have to deal with people who
immediately go to socialist this
and communist that and trumpy and free
markets and supply-side economics i mean
trash truly trash another question
are we going to figure out a way to
organize ourselves
so that we can live what i would call
sustainably on this planet
we can do it it's a matter of how we do
it not
whether we need to and we are rapidly
advancing in so many technologies
solar electric vehicles geothermal
carbon capture
but instead of having a society that is
doing
really an incredibly you know patriotic
or humanistic thing and saying we are
dealing with this right now we're all
together
furthering this technology and we're on
the same page that we just have to do
this for the sake of the human race
we've identified the problem and we're
dealing with it now instead
we are relegated to arguing with people
who won't even accept it's a problem
who think it makes a scientific point to
bring a snowball
inside uh indoors in washington dc in
winter
it's just a total garbage situation and
so
what i mean when i say i seriously hate
politics
is that i hate that this is what we have
to deal with when we engage
with the political system now obviously
to change the system
you have to engage with it if you just
ignore the system
bury your head in the sand you
accomplish
nothing other than letting the people
with the worst instincts
make all the decisions that's tragic and
that's devastating
and so in order to fix american politics
we do have to pay attention and we do
have to engage
with these retrograde disgusting
baseless ideas
and that's what i mean by hating
politics because we have to face
the reality that often feels like half
or more of the people around us are
quite literally working against the best
interests of humanity
i don't think we have much of a choice
but it's not good
it's not good and it's what i mean by
saying i hate it
and uh if you i mean listen if you think
that there's a way to change it without
engaging with it
let me know but i don't see that we have
much of a choice
while we were on vacation fox news host
tucker carlson
made the baseless claim at least as far
as he's presented evidence
that the nsa the national security
agency
had been spying on him and then the
story disappeared for a little bit
until yesterday tucker appeared on the
fox business program
mornings with maria hosted by the
notorious trump brown-noser maria
bartoromo
tucker is now saying that he recently
learned that
it will soon come out that not only has
the nsa been spying on him
but the nsa leaked the contents of his
emails to journalists
in an effort to discredit him in
relation to
i guess seeking an interview with
vladimir putin now he says it's not a
figment of his imagination
that it is very very real so let's look
at this
uh interview that he had with maria
bartoromo
and um these are very serious
allegations so let's listen to it
the nsa spying tucker carlson tonight
host
tucker carlson said last week on his
program that he has
information from a whistleblower showing
that the nsa
is spying on him and planning to leak
sensitive communications to get his show
canceled
tucker joins us right now tucker it's
great to have you this morning thank you
so much for being here
oh yeah you are the only people i get up
for maria it's an honor to be here
yeah it's you don't go on tv lightly
to say the government is spying on me
because you sound like a crazy person
and of course you would never say that
unless you knew that it was true and i
did know that it was true
almost accidentally i was in washington
for a funeral
last week and ran into someone i know
well said i have a message for you
and then proceeded to repeat back to me
details from
emails and texts that i sent and had
told no one else about um so it was
verified and this person said look the
you know
now what's important to understand here
is this is tucker's assertion
and we have to be able to distinguish
between
if what tucker is saying is true then
xyz versus simply tucker is making this
assertion
and as yet has not presented any
evidence for it now the first thing to
understand is
just because we would be skeptical of
this claim
because there's not yet been evidence
presented doesn't mean that we think the
nsa
is great or always acts appropriately
and this is a really important thing
in the trump era often when if you're on
the left and you say
hey you know what there's really no
reason to doubt the fbi when the fbi
said
x or there's really no reason to doubt
the cia when the cia said why
sometimes right wingers and even
sometimes leftists will say oh what now
you love the cia
which did all this bad stuff globally
for decades no no no
we're just looking at these claims the
nsa does spy on people that's what they
do
the nsa could leak stuff but tucker has
not yet presented evidence
and maybe he will so we're not laughing
this off if the nsa
is spying on tucker and leaking his
emails i want to know but
as you will see here he's not yet
presenting any evidence let's look at a
little bit more of this
it has this and that was proven by the
person repeating back
the contents of the email and is going
to use it against you now
to be totally blunt with you i would
never have said this in public if it was
something i felt was wrong or
illegal or immoral they don't actually
have anything on me but they do have my
emails so
i knew they were spying on me and and
again to be totally blunt with you
as a defensive move i thought i better
say this out loud
because i have no i have no other way to
defend myself i'm just an american
citizen i don't have
you know any position of official
authority but i do have a megaphone
he does have a megaphone it's a little
bit i mean listen when you have
one of the top rated shows on one of the
three major cable networks to say you're
no one special
essentially is what he's saying it's not
exactly representative of the spirit of
tucker's privileged position but let's
not
harp on that too much say this out loud
and i did
and the nsa didn't deny it then
yesterday okay i learned that and this
is going to come out
soon that the nsa leaked the contents of
my email to journalists
in an effort to discredit me i know
because i got a call from one of them
saying oh this is what your email was
about so
it is not in any way a figment of my
imagination it's confirmed it's
true they're not allowed to spy on
american citizens they
are okay so there's a there's a ton of
stuff there
now tucker says the nsa
didn't deny a part of this
let's look at what the nsa actually said
because i i think it's it's
important to actually see the wording
the nsa put out a statement
saying on june 28 2021 tucker carlson
alleged
that the nsa has been quote monitoring
our communications
and is planning to leak them in an
attempt to take this show off the air
this allegation is untrue tucker carlson
has never been an intelligence target
of the agency and the nsa has never had
any plans
to try to take his program off the air
nsa has a foreign intelligence mission
we target foreign powers to generate
insights on foreign activities
that could harm the united states with
limited exceptions like an emergency
the nsa may not target a u.s citizen
without a court order
that explicitly authorizes the targeting
now what what tucker is focusing in on
there
is that the nsa doesn't deny reading his
emails now it is possible
um and this you know with all of the
trump people
american trump people that were in
contact with russians
when the russians were being surveilled
which we could say we don't like that
this is what the nsa does but the nsa
has a foreign
intelligence mission when the nsa was
monitoring russians
when trump people communicated with the
russians incidentally
they observed the communications of the
americans who were in touch with the
russians right
so tucker then last night talked in more
detail about what this is all about
what if you listen to it it could
explain
some of this okay and then we'll talk
about whether it's okay i guess
god we're happy to report that late this
spring i contacted a couple of people i
thought could help get us an interview
with russian president vladimir putin
yeah i told nobody i was doing this
other than my executive producer justin
wells i wasn't embarrassed about trying
to interview putin he's obviously
newsworthy
i'm an american citizen i can interview
anyone i want
and i plan to but still in this case i
decided to keep it quiet i figured that
any kind of publicity would rattle the
russians and make the interview less
likely to happen
but the bide administration found out
anyway by reading my emails
i learned from a whistleblower the nsa
plan to leak the contents
so first of all it's important that when
when you say the biden administration
to you know that that's questionable
language for this if you understand how
you know trump was constantly
criticizing the fbi for things it did
during his administration
if you apply this logic that was the
trump administration right if any action
taken by fbi cia or nsa
uh during a presidency is that
presidency that administration doing it
then it was the trump administration
that did all the things that trump
criticized the fbi for i think that's
pretty dubious
emails to media outlets why would they
do that
well the point of course was to paint me
as a disloyal american
a russian operative been called that
before a stooge of the kremlin a traitor
doing the bidding of a foreign adversary
and of course i mean hardly the only
person who's been accused of those
things
so okay so so let's let's talk about
what's going on here now that we have
the full picture
um many of these allegations are just
unproven okay the
the leaks by the nsa to journalists all
it's
if there's evidence of that then i want
to see it i want to know what the nsa is
doing i don't think the nsa is uniquely
good or bad
uh american intelligence agencies
sometimes do good things sometimes they
do bad things sometimes it's not easy to
call something good or bad
if tucker carlson was in touch with
uh people he may or may not have known
are kremlin agents russian intelligence
who knows who tucker was in touch with
in order to try to get an interview with
vladimir putin
if those people were being monitored by
the nsa
then certainly by being in touch with
them tucker's communications would have
ended up monitored by the nsa this is
not hugely shocking or controversial if
you're talking to someone who's under
surveillance
like a foreign intelligence target then
by talking to them you're going to be
surveilled we can debate that's good or
bad
but it's not shocking so number one
is tucker going to present proof we'll
have to wait and see number two
where was tucker on this stuff for years
when
uh uh it was happening already
now all of a sudden that he believes or
is at least claiming it's happening to
him
it's his number one issue so there's a
lot of stuff here to clear up but i want
to be really clear
if what tucker is saying is true i want
to know about it but it wouldn't be
shocking
that if tucker is talking to people
foreign agents being surveilled by
american intelligence
it would be logical that his side of the
communication
is also going to be subject to that
surveillance not defending
it but it's exactly what you would
expect let me know your thoughts we'll
have more of this on our instagram
which you can find at david pakman show
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming
a member which gives you access to the
daily bonus show the regular show with
no commercials
you also get access to our entire
archive
of every episode dating back a really
long time
and plenty of other awesome membership
perks go to joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21
for a huge discount joinpakman.com
it's great to welcome to the program
today bill browder who is the ceo
of hermitage capital management head of
the global magnitsky justice campaign
and also
author of the book red notice um so bill
to
to start with the the story you tell in
your book
includes uh as you got into the world of
finance your interest
in eastern europe which included
initially doing some work
in poland when there was relatively
little work being done in poland by
us and british-based folks in the
finance world and eventually actually
going
to russia itself um talk a little bit
about
how that all worked and how you ended up
working in that part of the world
sure so um i went out to
russia in 1992 just at the beginning of
the
russian privatization program basically
when when the soviet union broke up uh
russia became uh sort of you know quote
democracy
um uh the new president wanted to go
from communism to capitalism
and in order to do that they they
basically uh the state owned all the
property and they said we're going to
give all the property away for free to
the people
and make them capitalists and um
uh and and of course as we know a lot
most of the property ended up in the
hands of a very small number of
russian oligarchs but there were little
crumbs falling off the table
and those crumbs were shares of some of
the biggest russian companies which were
trading on the stock market
and i went and set up a business called
the hermitage fund
to basically pick up those crumbs and
invest in the
newly privatized companies um and
for a while it was just uh bonanza like
bigger
profits you know i guess you know made
cryptocurrency
gains you know look like child's play it
was just so
the the returns were so great so you
eventually got involved in this space
where there was the possibility of
investing in russian companies at
massive discounts from what traditional
finance measures would assess as the
value
of these companies talk a little bit
about
how you how that worked how you got into
that
well so the situation was that that um
nobody really understood what was there
it was a sort of a state secret
the oil industry was a state secret um
uh
you know all these big companies were
not known
um to the russians and the russians had
these these uh
vouchers they called them privatization
certificates and they could
invest their vouchers and whatever they
wanted to invest them in or sell their
vouchers
and most russians didn't really think
that their vouchers would be worth
anything and so they sold them for a
bottle of vodka and
and various people were were buying up
vouchers and this voucher exchange
exchanges formed and and uh i did the
math and
and i said okay if you buy shares and
some of these oil companies you're
buying
oil at like 10 cents per barrel of oil
reserves in the ground and at the time
oil prices were let's say trading at 30
dollars
and so 10 cents in the ground versus 30
out of the ground that that kind of had
to be a good deal
and so um but but to tell you the truth
it was
it was really hard to get people
interested in the west in that i would
say look here you know these things are
trading at a 99.9
discount and most people when they heard
the word russia they
like ran for the hills and so it wasn't
like um
this was something that was like the
slam dunk you know
obvious to most people most people said
well you know whatever the valuations
are
i don't want to go anywhere near russia
so ultimately
um you fell out of favor in russia
um and ultimately were even
expelled from the country legal problems
what what went wrong how did the problem
start to develop
well so the companies that i so i ended
up getting becoming the largest
foreign investor in russia we had four
and a half billion dollars
invested in all these companies and what
i discovered was all the companies were
basically being robbed blind
by these oligarchs who were the majority
shareholders
and so um i decided to try to start
fighting the um the thievery the robbing
of these companies
by exposing it and in doing so
um uh you know in in in these
dictatorships and third world countries
uh business and politics are all sort of
intertwined and so
the moment that i started exposing all
these nasty things going on
um all of a sudden the politics got
involved and i was expelled from the
country
i was declared a threat to national
security my offices were raided
they seized all of our documents and the
next thing we knew
those documents were used to perpetrate
a a
highly complex fraud where they then
stole our companies
and used those companies to steal 230
million dollars of taxes that my company
had paid
to the russian government and so it was
all
politics mixed with business mixed with
criminality
and i was on the receiving end of all
that stuff right
so people may or may not know
but russia is a huge country
it has extremely rural areas
and those rural areas have courts
and often those courts are operating
under the direction of um who knows
who in power bribes corruption
etc talk a little bit about how that all
worked i mean that that was really the
basis for how
these assets and companies were taken
from you
yeah so russia is a very formalistic
place so so um
it's not like you know in like i don't
know in mexico or i don't know where
you know they just grabbed your stuff
and that's and that's done
in russia everything is is sort of done
with some kind of pretense
and and so they'll go to the court and
the court just the the judge will make a
decision to transfer your
assets to somebody else and he'll stamp
that he'll stamp the
uh judgment and and and so they they
love all this sort of procedural
bureaucratic stuff um even though you
can just you know unwind it
and and show that it's all been done
fraudulently and for some reason that
that doesn't um
you know even if you can show us done
fraudulently that doesn't bother them
they can all just wave their court
decisions in the air
based on a you know 500 bribe they made
to the judge and
that's the order of magnitude of bribes
that they probably had to make in order
to get these kinds of decisions
through the courts so you tell
one story and um the way i like to
sort of when i when i read a non-fiction
book about something i'm not already
familiar with i first
don't look up anything about it i just
read the book and then i'll look up well
what are the other perspectives about it
and after reading your
book and and hearing your story doing
some research
as well for this interview i come across
allegations
that you were not actually the victim
but
you actually were the perpetrator in
other words you use
the systems that you criticize and say
that victimized you to actually
participate
in the corruption and in the fraud now
it's beyond my ability to adjudicate
these things in independently in the
context of this interview
you tell one story there are others who
tell another story
uh but what do you make of the fact that
there are these counter allegations that
have been made that say you are actually
the perpetrator here and not the victim
well i mean well first of all those
allegations were made
by the people who stole the money so
um and so so we have we have a uh
i mean and just so you know in in russia
this is what they do they shoot down a
plane going over russia
um and they blame it on the on the the
people who were you know on the plane
or or i mean everything is the other
guys did it
and and uh in in our case uh
you know it's the whole thing is sort of
completely absurd from top to bottom the
money was
stolen um in so so our companies were
stolen
and and all of these sort of
machinations were done
in to in in december like october
december of 2007.
and we filed a criminal complaint with
with all the major russian law
enforcement
agencies after we learned about the
theft of our companies
and we put that onto the record
and three weeks after we filed our
complaint
the tax money was stolen the 230 million
dollars of taxes that we paid
and so what what criminals would would
file a complaint about their upcoming
crime
before they committed it i mean i mean
there are so there are so many
like errors in their story that they
they also blame the story
um that they say that that sergey
magnitsky my dead lawyer
um who was killed by the way for for
disclosing this
they say he stole the money and he did
it together with another dead guy
and the other dead guy died two two
months before the um the crime was
committed and so i mean
just you know these guys are like
keystone cops when it comes to
coming up with a conspiracy theory to
blame the other guy
so there um have been multiple red
notices
placed against you for people who don't
know what a red notice is a red notice
is
sort of a global interpol
arrest warrant or arrest directive in a
sense
and there were ultimately interpol
decided as you tell in the book
not to enforce that red notice they
decided this is politically motivated
this is bogus and they decided not to
enforce it but there was a period of
time where
as far as you knew if you had an
interaction
with customs or border authorities
in any number of countries you could
have been arrested and then extradited
to russia and then
who knows what would have happened how
long was that period of time
where that was a concern for you where
you didn't know what would happen
well so the book um i finished writing
the book in 2014
and the first interpol notice from
russia came
in 2013. the second one came in 2013
and since the book was written there
have been eight interpol
notices for my arrest from russia
and so when you say how long there's
been numerous
periods of time a week here two weeks
there three weeks
um where where if i crossed a border i
would be arrested
sent to russia to my death and um i was
arrested
in in may of 2018 i was traveling to
madrid
to meet with the spanish anti-corruption
prosecutor to share information
about russian uh money laundering
connected to the murder of my lawyer
sergey magnitsky and as i was walking
out of my hotel room
before my meeting with with the spanish
prosecutor
two spanish national policemen arrested
me on a russian
interpol warrant and it was only
because i was allowed to pack my bags in
my hotel room
before they took me away that i tweeted
out that i was being arrested
and then all hell broke loose with
journalists and
activists and everybody else um calling
interpol
calling the spanish government calling
everybody else so that by the time i got
to the police station i was released but
um uh this kind of stuff is pretty scary
and it continues to plague me up until
today the russians are after me
they've issued they found me guilty
twice
in their courts in absentia and have
sent me since being 18 years in prison
i'd be killed if i went back there no
question yeah you
you know what's interesting is you you
talk in the book about how
something that vladimir putin will do
sometimes when
he's asked about individuals that are
his adversaries
and this this happened with you he won't
say the person's name and so
there was a event you described in the
book where vladimir putin was asked
about you
and he referred to you i think as like
the gentleman you're referring to
when i was watching recently uh the
biden putin
press conference that took place after
their meeting
and putin was asked about navalny by a
journalist
it was almost verbatim what was said to
you uh putin
didn't say his name and said something
like
the person you're referring to
i believe has committed crimes in our
country which was
i mean that's essentially the same
language you describe is it not
well he used that language about me um
on a number of occasions
but but here's here's the interesting
thing so
after the magnitsky act was passed and
just for your listeners
um the magnitsky act is a piece of
legislation named after my lawyer
sergey magnitsky who was murdered after
uncovering
this 230 million dollar tax fraud that
these criminals and corrupt officials
committed
the magnitsky act was put in place in
the united states and other countries
which freezes the assets and bans the
visas
of russian human rights violators putin
got so angry
about the magnitsky act that he banned
the adoption of russian orphans by
american families
he made it his single largest foreign
policy priority
to repeal the magnitsky act he even sent
natalya veselnitskaya a russian lawyer
to trump tower
to meet with donald trump jr paul
manafort and jared kushner
before trump was elected to say if he's
elected please repeal the madminski act
um but here's here's the crux um
after the magnitsky act was passed he
started he he got
he had lost his he got so upset with me
that my name is now mentioned by
vladimir putin
and in fact he mentioned it very
profoundly um when he met with trump
when putin met with trump at the um
helsinki summit
and at the end of the summit um there
was this question about whether the
u.s whether russia would hand over the
uh 12 gru officers who hacked the
election
yeah and uh uh putin said well yeah
we'll hand them over
if trump hands over bill browder bill i
so appreciate
your time today the book is red notice
bill browder
is the ceo of hermitage capital
management and also head of the global
magnitsky justice campaign
i really appreciate your time today my
pleasure great to see you
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon
go to patreon.com david pakman show
where you can get access to behind the
scenes videos
the daily bonus show the commercial free
daily show
as well as special discounts on merch
including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts
you can support the show for as little
as
two dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com
davidpakmanshow all right this you have
to see just another
complete humiliation for the former
president donald trump who has been
hyping
up or had been hyping up a press
conference for yesterday morning
during which he was going to make a
major announcement
right wing news network newsmax hyped it
up
fox news talked about it a little bit
but not nearly as much it leaked
the press conference would be trump
announcing that he is
suing filing a class-action lawsuit
against facebook against twitter against
google
because they banned him and the event
was so humiliating
and so absurd that fox news even
cut away from it while trump was
answering questions
let's look at some clips starting with
the big announcement from the former
president dude i'm filing
as the lead class representative a major
class
action lawsuit against the big tech
giants including facebook
google and twitter as well as their ceos
mark zuckerberg zucker sunder
sundar buche that is
really uh really something else there
and god bless
the united states yeah um just a little
more here
and jack dorsey okay so that's the big
announcement
trump is really really mad that he's not
allowed to
tweet and so he's suing everybody
and of course it's an embarrassment that
he's even doing this i mean
you know everything including even like
see how he has it sort of looks like the
presidential lectern
but it's not it's it's kind of like a
low-rent copy of it
but where it really gets embarrassing is
the guy just doesn't understand the
first amendment
he just doesn't get it the founding
fathers
inscribed this right in the very first
amendment to our constitution because
they knew
that free speech is essential to the
prevention and look to the prevention of
hara hara that's h-a-h-r-r-a-h
if you're wondering and to the
preservation of our
republic this has nothing to do with the
first amendment
there there is just nothing here related
to the first amendment and
later we're actually going to hear from
alan dershowitz who wants to try to say
this is a first amendment thing
this has nothing to do with the first
amendment these are private companies
with terms of service
and i i don't want to get ahead of
myself we'll wait for the uh
we'll wait for the dershowitz thing
somehow at this event about trump suing
facebook and twitter
he ends up criticizing dr fauci a lot of
people ask me
about dr fauci i like dr fought you
actually get along with him great but
they said why didn't you fire him i said
no he was good
he'd recommend something i do the
opposite and we always turned out to be
right so i don't even know how that came
up and then
at this point fox news just cut away if
you tuned to fox
you you no longer saw this you instead
saw a really important story where jason
chaffetz was talking about the origins
of kovid okay
trump was then asked about what happened
on january 6th and and the
the question was a good one the framing
was well you know
the reason you ended up banned from
these platforms was because of what you
did on january
6th inciting violence and all this
different stuff so
what is your reaction to the fact that
that's what you did do you wish you had
done that differently
and somehow trump ends up talking about
antifa
just just to clarify um who should be
the arbiter of
what's hate what's offensive what should
not be
uh published what goes beyond free
speech yeah and because so much of this
uh your banning has to do with comments
you made around january 6th
just to clarify further what did you do
to
stop the insurrection as some people
call it right and
why were you not able to stop it so that
whole
event unfortunate event just went
through congress and a report it was an
unfortunate event guys that's all right
it just that that's that's all it was
back and standby
yeah um unfortunate it was issued and my
name wasn't even mentioned
and i appreciate that i was surprised
frankly because i would have assumed
that they would
have come up with their typically biased
at least on the democrats
statement the report came out as you saw
two weeks ago my name wasn't even
mentioned that was an unfortunate event
i say though however people are being
treated unbelievably
unfairly so trump is saying the peop the
perpetrators are being treated unfairly
he's asked what did you do to stop it
which is a you know
indirectly reminding us that he fomented
it and he says
it was unfortunate but the people who
did the stuff are being treated really
unfairly they're the victims here
when you look at people in prison and
nothing happens to
antifa and they burned down cities and
killed people
and there were no guns in the capital
that's not true burned
except for the gun that shot ashley
babbitt
and nobody knows who that men were if
that were the opposite way
this is trump by the way continuing to
try to dox that officer
that man would be all over he would be
the
the guy's been cleared you know it's
funny because when they
um when there's a situation where the
left is saying hey this officer acted
inappropriately
they immediately say no these these
officers we have to defer to their
judgment they're in positions of danger
etc
here there was an investigation and it
determined that the officer
did not not act inappropriately in
shooting ashley babbitt which was tragic
regardless but of course you shouldn't
have been there
um now all of a sudden trump wants the
guy doxxed if you can imagine most
well-known and i believe
i can say man because i believe i know
exactly who it is
but he would be the most well-known
person in this country
in the world but the person that shot
ashley babbitt
boom right through the head just boom
there was no reason for that
and why isn't that person being opened
up and why isn't that being
open them up just just just take a
scalpel to them and open them up so
trump somehow ends up talking about
you know antifa and who knows what else
and then this is sort of like trump's
new line
which really applies to himself and i
don't think that he really gets it
if you say it long enough hard enough
often enough
yeah people will start to believe it
true that's what happened with russia
that's what happened with ukraine that's
what happened with
well the worst is when they don't say it
like
the laptop from hell that laptop from
hell still really bothering trump and it
is true
if trump repeats that he won the
election long enough and if the people
around him start to repeat it
people start to believe it and that's
exactly what we're what we're seeing now
let's just briefly go
back to the first amendment thing here
is
alan dershowitz who has bizarrely become
a big defender of trump over the last
few years
saying this really is an important first
amendment case listen to this
understanding is you have some of the
tobacco attorneys
involved in that class action suit
involved in this case
seems like a strong case but obviously
nothing is a slam dunk
this is the most important first
amendment case of the 21st century and
it's important because
it pits freedom of speech on the one
hand
against the first amendment on the other
hand that may sound paradoxical but
remember
it's the high-tech giants that are
banning freedom of speech they are
censoring but they're
claiming the right to do so under the
first amendment so this is maybe
the biggest distortion i could imagine
about this story
okay so dershowitz wants to claim this
is about
whose first amendment speech is is
uh uh trump's the other does
trump have a first amendment right to
post to twitter and facebook and google
which are private companies
or do facebook twitter and google
have a right not only under the first
amendment but also under business
regulation law
which republicans are quick to defend
when
it's other situations to enforce terms
of service so it is not
actually a first amendment case that is
the
the big lie with this lawsuit is that
this is really the first amendment
versus free speech incentives
it's not it is not that this is quite
simply republicans who say
don't regulate business now want the
government to force
twitter to allow trump to tweet
that is fundamentally what this is about
and it's outrageous and the entire event
was humiliating it's going nowhere
it's going absolutely nowhere hey uh uh
things continuing to get worse for
donald trump's former personal attorney
rudy giuliani
rudy's law license has now been
suspended in washington dc
uh the district you might remember that
recently rudy's law license was
suspended in new york
the district of columbia now suspended
rudy giuliani from practicing law in
washington
this was triggered automatically because
giuliani was suspended in the state of
new york my understanding is that
rudy is in uh rudy is is
um via reciprocity allowed or was
allowed to practice
in dc and so when the state from which
you are
receiving the reciprocity uh suspends
your license you are essentially
automatically suspended
giuliani's license to practice law in
new york was suspended
in a ruling that cited his false and
misleading claims as statements about
the election
loss of former president donald trump
um getting suspended in one state in
this case prompting the automatic
or near automatic suspension in dc but
this is not really looking good for
donald
for uh rudy giuliani and you know what i
was thinking
if rudy giuliani for better or worse
in 2002 rudy giuliani had
extraordinarily high approval
he had been mayor of new york at the
time of 9 11.
he could have retired then and he would
have remained
i believe much beloved whatever you
think about his handling of 911 the
perception was that it was very good
and that he brought people together new
yorkers together americans together etc
he could have retired in 2002 he could
just have done
consulting he'd be rich he'd be powerful
he would be beloved
and instead he ends up known
for farting during bogus um
hearings if we can even call him that
about uh
completely laughable voter fraud claims
gets coveted uh takes him off of it
off of the the trail of doing these
hearings
then gets his law license suspended in
new york now it's suspended in dc trump
has reportedly completely abandoned rudy
it's not clear rudy has even gotten paid
the 20 grand a day that he was asking
for to represent trump
in the election fraud matter what a just
torpedoing of a guy who again like him
or not for better or worse like i'm not
a big giuliani guy but i recognize he
was
significantly well liked in 2002. not a
great decision for rudy giuliani as far
as i can see
maybe in his mind this is working out
great for him i just don't see it
we have a voicemail number and that
number is 2192 david p
here's a caller confronting me about joe
biden
take a listen to this hi this is tom
from maine
i'm willing to bet money that you're not
going to answer this question
let's bet how much you want to bet i'm
going to answer it right now
do you think biden should take a mental
acuity test
why or why not all right so listen i
believe and have said before
we should uh i don't know
constitutionally
if it can even be done so i'm not saying
legally this is feasible
but my belief is it would be great to do
more
screening and testing of people who want
to be
president so i would be if if we're
going to decide
every presidential candidate gets a
montreal cognitive assessment for
dementia that's fantastic do it
if we want to decide every president has
to
at least respond to basic
american history and constitution
questions maybe they're not barred from
running if they fail the test
but just so that we have the information
this is how this candidate did this
i'm fine doing a whole bunch of this
stuff okay i have no problem with that
whatsoever
what is absurd is that on the basis
of calling the montreal cognitive
assessment
um a mental acuity test when really it's
a
it's a course that's coarse
it's a course dementia screening when
trump lies about
the difficulty the point of the test the
number of questions
when bogus videos are used of joe biden
to justify
joe biden needing to take it or because
dr
ronnie jackson says biden should take it
none of those are reasons for biden to
take it
i'm fine with biden taking this test no
problem if you want to make it a
requirement of every candidate i'm
completely with you
the story that the right has woven about
this test is totally bogus about what
the test even is and what it does and
everything about it
and that's where i have a problem on the
bonus show today we'll talk about bill
cosby
we will talk about a four day work week
we will talk about
a heat wave becoming a mass casualty
event it's insane what's going on
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show get instant access
by signing up at joinpacman.com
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blast light is the world's smallest and
most convenient
uvc disinfection light to help keep you
safe
against covid19 i take mine everywhere i
go
go to davidpakman.com blastlight to get
it for 40
off the link is down below